yeah Chloe she's good she's doing really
good thank you for asking I'll tell her
you did okay it's been a lot and I think
we all need more malika's in our life
you know what I mean like I'm able to be
Malika because I have a Chloe as well
it's a it's a we take care of each other
you don't I mean like there's weird a
duo that's really tough to come by but
we're blessed to have each other and we
build off of that
and what do you think it is about you
that is that makes you such a good
friend what are these ideals that you
kind of stick to I've had the same best
friend for many years we don't judge
each other we can tell each other when
either one is right or wrong but no
matter what we just stick together
that's all that's all that really
matters to us and when you have someone
that has your back no matter what it's
like a family member it's like you know
your mother was like you're in trouble
you're wrong but I still got your back
that's the nature of our relationship
are you like being an t it's the best
thing ever true is the cutest smallish
brown version of Chloe I could imagine
look or are you spoiling her by far like
you know what you just don't say no to
true it's actually very difficult so yes
I spoiled her whatever listen but that's
what auntie's do of course mom has to
tell her yes and no and you could spoil
my job not my job not only is Malika
Haqq Khloe Kardashian's loyal BFF they
also recently decided to work together
besties people love the product that
we've given so they can share it with
their BFF et spoke with Malika at the
daily front Rose fashion la Awards honor
to be here you are like a little
entrepreneur CEO and what does that feel
like for to be recognized for that I
think it's really good to be yourself
and have people love you for who you are
and if you can give back to anyone in
any way you've won I think it was a big
deal though for when this collection
came out because it was for every girl
you know your yeah you you you don't
pick oh the cool kids table and you
can't sit with us you know have you
always been like that they're your
entire life I think I really stuck to my
group and I think the good thing about
my group were all kind of raised the
same by very strong women that literally
just encouraged you to like be true to
yourself love God love God love others
you don't mean like just just in and
embody that so other people can do that
get school I'm Who I am I'm fun I'm
Corki I make mistakes I do all kinds of
crazy things that I'm I'm happy what is
next on your to-do list girl 2019 I am
you know the Becca collection has really
opened me up to beauty and I would love
to do some things in some other areas
not at liberty to speak about it just
yet but I but I definitely want to do
some really good beauty things I mean
you have the most amazing skin of all
time so if you were to launch like a
skin care hair I would I'm in there for
all of that thanks babe I appreciate
[Music]